ragazzi oggi è domenica domani inizio e
video sul secondo canale quindi andate a
iscrivervi c'è l'ostacolo iscritti e
questa è l'ultima entro che farò per
dire che un secondo canale nel caso non
si fosse capito quindi andate a
iscrivervi non perdetevi video anche lì
è buona visione per i video di oggi
bella ragazzi erano tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti avessero stampa dj come vedete
dallo schermo siamo per giocare un gioco
che a me fa impazzire phinet e freddi
sguardi wanted che rende il gioco se non
fosse horror presti button vado resto t
button tim burton
ciao freddi forza vacca quanto ci ho
voglia di giocare a storo per noi vedere
stai fermo tu ti vedo ora in realtà
possiamo andare avanti ultima volta sono
preso interpretazioni infarto
solo che era la notte numero due poi ci
siamo la notte schiacciato tasto oggi
teoricamente siamo alla notte e numero 3
mi spieghi come ci arrivo io al bancone
non spiegano fatti lancio le mani come
arrivo milan se in scena ma perche sto
giocando sta roba
mio dio va ai ragazzi allora facciamo
una roba recente proviamo a vincere
notte numero 3 la più difficile finora
arrivare fino qui è stato un casino però
va beh non so se ce la farò mai ci
proviamo nei suoi valori ammazzato era
l'otto sorella spegne il telefono
spegnerò che viaggiava il casino tu ci
manca solo guerra allora ragazzi piano
controlliamo innanzi tutor nei monitor
dove sono i ragazzoni allora qua no
quando saranno all'inizio ecco lì sono
tutti qua ecco già uno se ne è andato
che non so chi
eccolo e chica dal ragazzino non mi
ricordo mai bene i nomi c'è freddi circa
fossi bagni e poi ce n'è una
non so chi è colui e bagni fantastico
non c'è più nessuno e la stanza di prima
c'è solo freddi e tra l'altro ancora
hanno visto freddi e tra tutti preti non
s'è ancora fortunatamente non sai come
presentato mancano ancora quattro ore
fantastico ciao zia ok ma posso più di
questa porta del gesù per favore ragazzi
sto gioco e o li videro disinstallo dopo
sto video ve lo giuro
quando ricavato evitato all'infarto che
non sa della mia vita
mamma mia che in fatto evitato va bene
sono a 50 per cento della batteria siamo
alle 3 del mattino cosa facciamo
schiatto qua e di là da ben saprete
chiudi la porta bene me lo spieghi cos'è
sto casino me lo vuoi dire che chiede
fate casino di no ragazzi io sempre di
rumori a sinistra e mi sto pagando
addosso allora siamo al 38 per cento di
batterie serale ho chiuso ecco infatti
ha fatto bene spegni ti bene che basta
lasciatemi in pace un attimo 30 per
cento
4 del mattino la gancia farò mai io ve
lo dico
ecco freddi folco schifo il demonio è
sveglia beni a vade retro satana
bastava stage casini
[Musica]
michele brutto gioco manca ancora amore
al 15 per cento gioco ormai ragazzi dura
meno della batteria dell'iphone sta roba
no ma io non ce la posso fare no no
ragazzi ma preferisco una verifica di
matematica sta roba 5 per cento manca
un'ora la rinuncia farò mai
ho perso te ne vai a quel paese per
favore no ragazzi possibile ad maria
piena di grazia signore con te ce l'ho
fatta da cigarettes fax server
pensavo di morire tantissimo non ci
credo allora per quanti oggi la strada
[Musica]
tra 4 o sfasciato la manovella prova be
fa niente grazie della torta sembrano
minori pacman a non si può mangiare solo
l'avevi se ne frega via ragazzi ho vinto
ho vinto già una notte non può esistere
ma ci sono un sacco di cose che puoi
fare ma che figo quindi io praticamente
con la notte quattro finisco il primo
phinet freddy's ma veramente ragazzi
avete proviamoci
so già che viene tempi no però proviamo
a fare un 94
maronna ragazzi no per favore per favore
pronto mamma ho già mangiato per
cortesia non lo aveva mangiato 87 per
cento vi prezzi per il sede non ho fatto
niente se non esasperarli nella mia vita
ho lee bile cosa rivi sta arrivando
fossili ha sbattuto la testa sulla porta
a posto
la prossima volta hai peccato il
famigerato so ma cosa sta cosa che sento
ogni tanto a destra lo saprei la porta
no è no la canzone no per favore
ogni quanto arriva cozzi se posso
chiedere mia madre urlava uguale quando
le portavo la pagella
va bene riproviamoci allora stiamo calmi
ma calmi perché io vi ammazzo i cugini a
tutti sapevano serve a qualcosa è un
test boomerang come possibile pronto a
parare il rigore pronto a parare rigore
prontissimo lo sento quadro co.co.co a
posto
vai a casa tua
ragazzi stiamo andando meglio di prima
però magari se non parlo gioco e meglio
è andato vattene per favore non puoi
stare due ore di buy mia che schifo è
andato e noi siamo lì per per la
smettiamo di giocare sti giochi e
iniziamo a giocare un po di più a
martedì per favore chi me lo fa fare
chiudi la porta sono stupido della festa
si sono riversati a galla sta roba
beh va beh mamma mia che spavento io sto
tenendo le porte chiuse da un'ora
arriverò allo zero per cento di batteria
in 4 secondi ve lo dico ragazzi facciamo
creare chiudo sembri un po crash
bandicoot però che brutto allora ci
cambiamo tutti puoi stare calma vuoi che
ti prendo sberle probabilmente perdere
tutto il braccio però abbiano cipro no
non riusciva a cliccare fisico
arrivabile va bene e 80 per cento si può
fare si può fare
si può fare io mica lo hanno sentito le
porte non si può fare ecco qualche fatto
bene per una volta che ci azzecco nella
vita sapete cos'è dovrei installare la
playstation al bagno meno studio quasi
gioco evidente successo se mi cadde
addosso sono costo però non so se si può
fare non c'è la presa della corrente nel
magno posso aprire bene no perché la
batteria sta andando a farsi [ __ ]
siamo solo al 50 per cento pensate
togliete sto casino non sento niente
io non ho capi non ho capito se sta
canzone che c'è è qualcosa che devo devo
fare per toglierla se non arrivano
oppure se solo per distrarmi non lo
capisco
nel dubbio chiudo la porta l'ho sentito
passi a posto ben 44 per cento 3 di
notte
porca vacca porca vostra dry fatevi
un'abilità che schifo di gioco e spegni
ti fossi anni la durata è stata mossa e
smettila di adil mcmenu ragazze basta a
cadere la vita giocate video games
iscriviti agiva quindi secondo canale
anche il primo 6 voglio ma come 16 per
cento
ma porca vacca la batteria andata a
farsi [ __ ] bene in tutto questo devo
tenere una porta chiusa perché c'è un
tizio lì no ma ragazzi impossibile non
sei per cento non c'è ormai non può non
posso vincere ma te ne vai
basta quanto stai no ragazzi sono morto
zero per cento manca ancora un ora lo
farò mai
se mi fai spaventare senza preavviso di
fico una testata
basta va bene così sono con te questa
era la quarta notte ragazzi sono
arrivato a 5 ore e sono morto
se le ebrei ma tua sorella va bene basta
basta ho fatto in due episodi ho fatto
quasi 4 notti e quasi è un record per me
è un record se farò un altro episodio
prendo qualcun altro lo faccio fare
pietro e non lo faccio solo notte
quattro non lo faccio su tante altre
modalità che ci sono purtroppo perché
non ho fatte tante ma perché l'ho
comprato stagione spero che mi sia
piaciuto lasciate un bel commette un mi
piace iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate
la campanina che trovate vicino a tassi
iscriviti per avere le notifiche
conoscono i video sempre che io non mi
prendono in fatto prima e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]